we are 10 days into 2023 and this year
many people are already setting goals to
improve their health and their
well-being Amazon books editorial
director Sarah gellman hears you and
she's here with her top picks to help
with very different goals that you may
have for the New Year good morning sir
good to see you good morning nice to see
you I like starting with the first book
because it's about the study of
happiness and I love the title The Good
Life we should say it's a division of
Simon Schuster published by that but
that's not why this is on your list no I
love this book so much I feel like I
need to apologize to every person I've
talked to since I read this because I am
dropping it into every conversation it
just blew me away it basically takes
data and Science and puts it behind
something that we think is
unquantifiable which is how to live a
good life this is based on one of the
most ambitious studies of all time which
for 80 years and counting has been
getting first-hand accounts from a group
of people and their generations to come
all about what makes them happy taking
things like their heart rate looking at
their blood and what you find in this
book is that actually what makes you
happy is having fulfilling relationships
so this book gives you tips on how to do
that and it also says that no matter
your age it's not too late you can still
have great relationships in your life
seriously ask me that book I'm so glad
I'm taking that Sarah speaking of
relationships there's a book about
setting healthy boundaries boundaries
right relationships I definitely needed
this book this is by Melissa Urban she's
the co-creator of The Whole30 program
and she says that people especially
women feel like putting their own needs
and desires first is selfish and she
really feels like we need to have
boundaries in our life so she walks
through all these different situations
including giving you specific language
on how to do everything like tell your
colleagues that you're not going to be
working on this vacation setting some
boundaries with your in-laws which I
know we all need and also personal
boundaries like how to set a budget and
stick to it I want to ask you because I
know we're running out of time you're
recommending a book about the feeling of
awe yes tell us about that this is
that's my life everything is like that's
perfect well it turns out that awe is
actually very good for you having that
feeling will give mental and physical
health benefits for you so you are in
the right place and this book is all
about the study of awe that emotion
that's so misunderstood it's by someone
who studies the science of emotions and
he was actually a consultant on the
Pixar movie Inside Out I hope you never
lose a feeling of yeah when you have a
baby I know well but I've always been
like that everything sort of like blows
my mind you have a book about drinking
alcohol or not drinking alcohol right so
a lot of people are doing dry January I
am one of them this book well oh good
this is signed up huh yeah okay nice
let's talk after this book radically
changes the way that you will think
about alcohol basically it talks about
how our current culture markets alcohol
specifically to women things like yes
way Rose or Mommy juice and it talks
through the actual effects of alcohol in
your body which is really really
sobering and the author weaves in her
own personal story of abstaining from
alcohol as well as talking about the
scientific effects of alcohol and giving
you tips on how to stop drinking and the
last one about the impact of interior
design on your mental health now to put
those two together home therapy the
author is actually a family therapist
and she's an interior designer and this
is all about how your exterior space can
infect Your Inner Health you nailed it
again with no notes
with the no alcohol I think it's really
hard Clarity for Sarah Gilman so focused
and happy coming up we're gonna have
talk on the table we'll be right back
Sarah that was